meantime back in this country the
governor of the golden state came to
Washington today amid his battle with
President Trump over what California's
National Guard troops will enforce at
the Mexican border tonight correspondent
Peter Doocy reports on that rift and
whether it can be repaired
California's Governor Jerry Brown the
only Democratic governor of a border
state says he's pretty close to a deal
to become the last border state to
fulfill president Trump's wish of
sending hundreds of National Guardsmen
to the border the guard is chomping at
the bit ready to go but there's a catch
California's Guardsmen are not going to
try to keep nonviolent border crossers
out in DC today Governor Brown stood by
the letter he sent to DHS secretary
Kirsten Neilson which says in part it
will not be a mission to round up women
and children or detain people escaping
violence and seeking a better life
President Trump who recently
reintroduced Browns decades-old nickname
Moonbeam to the discussion meant to
portray the governor as too liberal
tweeted looks like Jerry Brown and
California are not looking for safety
and security along their very porous
border the governor shot back that
certain statutes are being followed wait
a minute he's trying to stop drug
smuggling human trafficking and guns
going to Mexico to the cartels that
sounds to me like fighting crime Brown
blames Republicans in Congress and their
failure to pass comprehensive
immigration reform for adding anxiety to
the lives of illegal immigrants who have
led otherwise lawful lives for years
it's just an inflammatory football that
very lowlife politicians like to exploit
while inspecting border wall prototypes
last month President Trump
lashed out at Brown for his state's
sanctuary city policy Brown now 80 years
old has three presidential campaigns
under his belt is he positioning himself
for a fourth
I can't think less attractive than a
Democratic presidential primary
Governor Brown admits Democrats are
having some identity problems right now
and that looking ahead to 2020 a new
leader of the party has not emerged yet
Brown says he's looking but while he
does he's the one who's got president
Trump's
tension at least for today Bret Peter
thank you